are we six feet apart
six about six feet apart all right we
got a social distance bro
yeah it's good though you know we gonna
make it work
hey uh first of all mazzy the new album
is out and i gotta say man
i feel like uh you've leveled up every
album
quality why i just feel like you're
getting better man nah for sure i
appreciate that um fully my intentions
yeah like you know being first of all
i'm assuming there's been a lot of
opportunities where you could have
gone major why why
at this point are we still staying
independent
shout out to empire because we got a
plaque there's a plaque right here oh we
got one of them you know what i'm saying
you gotta you got that's that's that's
your name on there one up top aki some
stocky in the choppy huh
a hundred um i think you know i'm just
comfortable i'm comfortable with the
uh the independent lifestyle um you know
and uh i just know how to tweak it to
where it benefits me and mine
so i'm just i'm gonna just squeeze it
for what it's worth
i feel like over the last couple years
the
mainstream like the taste makers have
really started to embrace what you're
doing what do you think was like
the point in time where the narrative
changed where you were like okay
i'm like you know i know the black
panther soundtrack had to be one of
those moments but
leading up to that i feel like finally
you were getting a lot
a lot of the respect that you had been
deserving for a few years we can't
overlook the kendrick lamar shout out
either
100 um i think you know just seeing the
embracement
of others i think you know people just
see
other people embracing other people them
set me up their statue
embrace you know the epic coming and um
they follow suit that's it you know if
somebody get if somebody starts sizzling
right now
and we pick up on him and embrace him
you'll see other people that's in my
lane pick up on him and embrace him so
i just feel like people just following
suit and you know they actually
it's the exposing so you know by others
embracing it
they're exposing me to you know their
fan base
and the crowd of people that that
function with them
and so um you know they pick up on so
they fan base they pick up on that new
and new sound or they pick up on
something they like and they start
functioning with it
and um exploiting it to others it's
stuff like um
like double xl freshman covers that kind
of [ __ ] those kind of accolades like
matter to you at all
hell yeah i was hot i'm sad i ain't get
freshman at a year
i felt like i was worthy and deserved
especially out of ten
man list out of ten that's what i'm
saying they put together
and yeah and you ain't and mize ain't up
there and then you got you know no
disrespect but you got a couple of
theodorks and peons up
bunch of [ __ ] yeah i'm saying and uh
now you know i just feel like uh
it turned political it just turned
political but double xl is my people and
i love them dearly you hear me
i just take them little um you know i
take it on the chin i take it on the
chin
evidently you know i wasn't politically
tied in or i didn't put in enough work
either or
and um i don't blame nobody but me so i
go back to the drawing board get it in
bite down and find that hunger drop
and and make them respect something so
your album's coming out it's obviously
it's out today days down
the day the album dropped last night
drake announces he's putting out a
project
how do you vote i mean you know shout
out to drake but like that's got to kind
of be like well [ __ ] man like
my ankle lie wasn't really tripping i
heard it i seen it and
i really didn't react you know shout out
to drake he'd do what he want when he
won't
and um i got that same type of attitude
i do what i want when i want
and you know i don't care who dropped
you know i'm seeing me um
on the day that i drop you know it just
make it more memorable
it give it more you know i don't mind
drink dropping that that's big mazzy and
drake drop
you got me in the same conversation you
got and you got and you got a
thing of salute you got some [ __ ] to get
sensitive to and you got some
some gangster [ __ ] nah yeah i got it on
it's on there man and uh
you know if if y'all comparing my album
to drake [ __ ]
your album is better i can't do nothing
but smile my boy
yeah yeah you're not about to drink
album is a great bodywork man appreciate
it
on the project you were saying if people
mistaking you just being a rapper that'd
be a mistake
that'd be a mistake man i'm much more
than that um
and i you know on that on the album i
was referring to it
as a you know as a street politician
but in actuality just period point blank
in general
i'm much more than that i'm much more
than that to my family i'm much more
than that to the streets of sacramento
slash o park i'm much more than that to
you know the west coast
alone because um you know when i get to
test the people i really touch them
and uh you know we all identified with
the same struggle so
they consider me one of theirs 100 um
the quarantine [ __ ] with this covert 19
[ __ ] how has
besides live shows and [ __ ] like that
like how has it affected
your life you know what i'm saying like
i mean you look like you're healthy you
look like you're doing well
all the prices went up prices on the
tissue
you know i'm saying prices on the
napkins price is not
i'm just no you're right though listen
bro you go to 7-eleven right now and
you hey 7.99 for sanitizer
come on now but uh outside of that uh
first and foremost send my condolences
love respect
to the family that lost family during
this time
i know it's a serious you know this is
this is something serious man and
i take it seriously but um
you know i ain't been highly affected
i'm an entertainer so
my check been rolling in and if somebody
in my family's been affected by it i
i assist you know what with what i can
and so we all gucci and gabbana the
schools
i i'm you know my daughter at home so
she her being out of school
that affects um you know spend more time
with your daughter yeah but now i'm
enjoying it i ain't gonna lie i'm
enjoying the whole process man i
wouldn't mind if if the world stay like
this
uh we because you it's less value on
materialistic things and uh you know
we just it's more family-oriented
oriented
so um man i'm enjoying it man i ain't i
ain't got no complaints
what's been the wildest [ __ ] i mean i i
think i feel like i've watched all the
netflix
but like have you been binge watching
any tv shows or like what have you been
like
doing i've been tapping they got one
called uh
first and foremost i just watched that
last night what is it all day in the
night
oh they got some of the hell gang music
in here
shout out to um the production team and
everybody behind that
but i've been watching first 48's fire
um my slide in the house and what
will we turn on oh did you see the tiger
one titan tiger
tiger king yeah i tweaked that joe
exotic
joe that's my boy hey yo
i'm not sure i'm not sure if that was
him really singing but if it was he
could he could sing with him
he was doing this dougie he was doing
this
i think it might have been him lip
seeking some other i i don't know if he
could sing that well
all right he would do it would you would
you do a record with joe exotic
right now i'm saying
cook up you feel me uh gang-related
jungles
that should have been great dropper ap
gang related jungles you i'm seeing me
yo it's crazy because i remember the
first time i met you
it was like 2017 you came up to the
station you remember you freestyled over
triumph it would tank beat for us
and at that time you were
this was like mozzie leaned out
on a cloud mozzie you see me i fell
asleep on you and
yeah you was like in another world no i
was i was in a whole nother world man
during that whole time
yeah and i remember like yo he's still
like you killed it but i remember like
i remember talking to uh you know
talking to ghazi like man this if this
guy could get his [ __ ] together like
he's a star you know what i'm saying
like
um and then what i thought was so dope
man was you were the first rapper
to really make it okay to like kick the
cup
you started that you started to kick the
cup challenge for sure
most definitely and i feel like it was
needed because like
that wasn't cool at that point in time
and it was like somebody somebody needed
to step out and be like yo man
you know it's it's okay to kick this
[ __ ] nah yeah they banged me upside my
head for that too
i remember them they bashed me upside my
head all type of people um
but i wasn't mad at it based on i feel
like it benefited more
than than anything it benefited a lot of
people you know i'm saying more than
anything so
um i wasn't mad at it man i'll take i'll
take the lick and this was prior to like
you know
obviously a lot of people are trying to
get clean now because a lot of people
have passed away you know juice world as
well yeah this is before all right this
is before all this when it wasn't cool
when it wasn't bully bull to kick the
cup
this one it was [ __ ] what you talking
about kick the cup [ __ ]
i'm seeing me um you know that was
tweaking on me
but i ain't mad at it like i said i'll
take the lick and i'm seeing me if
somebody could benefit off of it
was that still uh is that still
something you struggle with because i
know that that's
you know recreationally it's around i
just said it in my song
man uh you know at least i don't promote
it on the grim this is my addiction
though
he said i told the road i quit he said i
forgot how it got soldered
i quit but i ain't get uh oh told the
rod i quit it's hard to kick it though
at least i don't promote it on the
ground it's my addiction though
and numb the pain that i be going
through who are you the judge i miss you
brenda usher without you i've been
secluded love
so now yeah um you know i had a little
bar in my song where
you know i was admitted to admitting to
relapsing
right and um but you're not glorifying
it not but i don't glorify it man i
don't paint it is this is something that
somebody
so these is my real struggles this is
what i i deal with these are my everyday
struggles
i'm a real human being and i'm seeing me
and i go through things and
i find methods and ways to to numb it
and uh you know this is my battle these
one of the battles that you know i'm
saying
i'm in the ring whitney i got a face but
i wouldn't advise nobody i love
nor nobody you love to indulge in them
type activities
um lyrically like on some mc [ __ ] i feel
like
you're like top notch man i feel like
you're especially on the west coast like
when i think of like
fella yeah like when i think like like
who can melt somebody on a 16 i'm like
all right mozzie's one of those guys
like
who is somebody who you respect on that
level as like a rapper
who like even like yo man i like if you
were to do a record with you might be
you guys did a whole project together
whole project he wanted them people that
i i get in there and
you know it's a spicy situation you know
what i'm saying me we it's
it's spunky smoke you know what i'm
saying and uh
you know i know he gonna dish it out and
so i gotta return fire
he go brazy uh who else i respect on
that level
outside of my camp i'm saying cause you
know the sully rules
he go great eat my snubs this them they
are competitive and they make
but um yeah i say surf and um you know
nip i used to feel that way about nick
100 g.o.d like i gotta tweak when i get
in here with him i can't
ain't no playing with it uh
um um it was one more oh my boy j-rock i
respect
j-rock of course i respect rocking the
way he rock out
it's a couple i respect a lot of people
that be shooting at israel man i ain't
gonna lie it's some people that
that can dance in that booth you talk
about j-rock obviously kendrick putting
you on that black panther soundtrack was
a a
a big look man um was there ever any
dialogue of you signing with tde or was
that discussion ever happen like did
they ever like
show interest because i feel like you
would have fit in td function with me i
ain't got a lot of they didn't throw me
so many alley oops man and i can't wait
to return a favor
g-o-d i feel like i'm in debt with them
people man
um love them was there ever like any
discussions are you signing signing with
them no i was you know i was i was
throwing that out there
yeah i'm saying right top dog what's
happening
brother brother but uh we saw family
oriented that you know
it it nobody we ain't never press play
on that and
you know i'm so bumpable and bully bull
with my little situation that
um i never really entertain anything
outside of it but
for sure i function with the whole tde
camp and uh
that'd be dope um you talked about like
you know your relationship with empire
shout out to ghazi uh
what is it about working with ghazi that
like you
you don't think because a lot of you
know i feel like empire's this
island in the middle of the music
industry that some people know about but
other people are like what what is going
on over there like what is it about
working with
with empire and ghazi that to you is
like special and sets
sets that company apart because i know
ghazi's one of the smartest guys i know
so
coming out the trenches i felt like
when i talked to entert i mean um record
labels
my main request was uh you know just
freedom to do whatever i want as far as
creatively and uh that's what they offer
they tell me i'm entitled to do whatever
i want they ain't trying to change my
music
they ain't try to dilute it they ain't
come with no like look you should do
this and
you know they don't even suggest things
that that's out of my lane
you know and they let me be me they let
me do me i'm entitled to drop at will
um the fact that everything is so
transparent you know all the deals is
transparent it's like um
you know uh uh i say a 12th grader can
understand the whole
if if they sit down and talk with you
and you're a 12th grader
they could they could bust it down
somebody who's new to this business
never done any type of work in this
business they can they'll make it
transparent for you to understand
and then they'll follow through with
that it's not like you know
um you know how fine print is everything
is clear and um i was able to comprehend
and understand it and see that this is
the situation best is best for me it
benefits me
of course i wanted to take the long way
i didn't want to jump on the elevator i
wanted to run the stairs
so um you know and they and they
assisted me with that
and uh they got behind me man and like i
said their word is
is platinum anything they say they gonna
do they follow through
when they come with these deals or you
know however it's it's i feel like
i feel like they family i feel like if i
go broke today
i can call guys and say better better
you know i'm saying me from me one of
them imbelies man
right right right you're gonna fork it
over you feel me i feel like i could
call mean
name team i need 100k like today though
right and he had forked that over and
and that's i just it's crazy the
relationship that i got with him so
you know anytime i can i can um
persuade somebody in it not even
persuade man anytime i could recommend
you i'm seeing me or refer
somebody to the empire man i for surely
go about it
you've like throughout your career
you've been extremely active
like if we don't have a mozzie album
we'll have a collab project with you
and uh gun player you and sue or you
know i gotta stay lit man that's what
we're in it for yeah like
i feel like that that you know just your
activity has a lot of
a lot to do with your success right like
for sure what what are some
see um some some advice you would give
to independent artists because i feel
like
you've been building this for so long
but like i've noticed like i'm like yo
this guy don't give fans like a chance
to forget
like he's on top he's on the neck like
consistency is key
consistency is key and um you know know
who your market is
and reciprocate the love make sure you
give back man as much as you receive
straight up like the smallest things in
the world
it it go a long way with the fan base
just imagine you having an unconditional
love for an artist and you push up on
him
and they stiff-form you right you're
gonna feel some type of way you might
not feel the same way you felt
about that artist again you feel me so
you know i see the love i recognize
the love and i reciprocate it when i see
it
i make sure you know i dish out that
same energy
i make sure um i make sure i treat them
you know i i treat them like
like if it was the other way around if i
was the fan
and this was somebody i listened to and
how would i want to be
you know treated in this situation so
even when i'm tired
even when i'm exhausted or i'm with my
daughters and i don't feel like doing
this [ __ ] i'm tired of taking pictures
i'm tired of signing [ __ ] watch out
right feel me this is me time my time
um i still go out my way still go out my
way
and make sure you know that that they
leave
satisfied and um it's worked for me
it's benefited me man it's worked for me
and the crazy part about it is
it's not it's not hard or it's not a
task when um
when you're genuine about it when you
genuinely felt like that
and i'm saying same thing with this
music it don't feel like
work when you're passionate about this
this is this is
i'll do this for free i would love to
come do this interview
i'm saying this is this is me that's
what i that's what i signed up for
i've been waiting on this day i prayed
for this day i sat on a bunk and prayed
for this
so now that i'm here man i embrace it
wholeheartedly
and um you know at anything i do i mean
i give it my all so
i just i say stay stay consistent
and um you know just reciprocate the
love man
even i don't care how small it is if
it's somebody reposting your [ __ ] on
instagram
if it's somebody a dj shouting you out
man on the radio out of nowhere
just make sure you know you you you get
at that love right back
and uh yeah build your build on top of
that that's something to build on
you talk about getting locked up i know
the last time you
you you you were down when you got out
you had a battery in your back
yeah that was kind of what kind of like
was
was was that motivation to really get on
this campaign
for sure um take us back to that that
that mentality when you when you went to
jail last time and you was sitting in
your cell thinking about like damn
i can't take what i got for granted
because i remember talking to you and
you were like
[ __ ] knew who you were in jail
and [ __ ] you know what i'm saying not
for sure they get on me too like the
homies the homies be
they'd be devastated when i slide
through usually you know it's a
celebratory situation
right one of the homies coming in gang
they let you in here for a while
you lightweight you i'm saying
undercoverly hoping that [ __ ] got a
little time so he can come bigger with
you right
kick it with the hook they'd be
disturbed when i slide in there
like you know i'm saying what is you
doing and i'm talking about the ones
that genuinely love me
anybody else they happy to see me but
the ones who genuinely love me the ones
who watch me struggle
and i'm standing and watch this marathon
take place
you know they um they feel some type of
way man
and i appreciate that and that go a long
way
so when i be in there i just it'd be
like brett [ __ ] you better get it
together
don't double back here [ __ ] you double
back here [ __ ] is
it's up and um you know i'll be in there
playing and plotting
strategizing writing down what i'm gonna
do how i'm gonna do it
how long is it gonna take me to do it
and i'm saying and
and when they crack the gates but i'm
sitting in there i'm sitting in there
and i'm impatient
i wanna do it now anything that i can do
right now over this phone
i'm calling home and i'm trying to get
it done bro we got to do this bruh
bruh we got it you know i you know it's
ugly for me right now but soon as i get
out i'm telling you bro
i need to hold this and we got to do
this hey hit dude and tell dude this
it was like a machine and moving and you
trying to keep it afloat
and you're impatient and you can't wait
because you could taste it
and then they crack them gates man and
you get the chow down you get the bite
down
you get to prove it so when i came home
i already knew i was fake way gang
i was like like gang chief you know i'm
saying and that's how
that's how the gang test was teach uh
treat me
so uh you know the suckers was on my
line like you know i'm head honcho we
gotta clean him up
and um i was so i was you know i was
they knocked
i got shot at a lot whatever the case
but um
even going through cps fighting cps
fighting probation i'm saying getting
into it with the homies because
you know i'm shooting up so it's just
like
all odds against you it's like it's
crazy
and um i was still able to juke move and
hurdle jump over them hurdles and them
obstacles and
and still overcome all the all the
negatives and everything that was
against me man and
and find and find my niche and so uh
it's just crazy it's crazy
hella thankful beyond blessed and um i'm
grateful a lot of gratitude
so i try to give back in any shape and
form
like i feel like every time i see you
bro like or just over the years man like
i feel like
you're somebody who's always improving
like as a person
not sure whether it's maturity whether
it's
the way you conduct yourself whether you
know you're always leveling up you know
what i'm saying got to you got to that's
what we're getting for it man um i'm
raising girls i'm raising girls and
you know i can't i can't i can only give
them the best
of me so if i'm not bettering myself
then i feel like i'm i'm cheating them
i'm giving them less
so i gotta you know it's time you gotta
educate yourself
you gotta stay um stay focused
determined
you got to um make sure you financially
if you if you financially illiterate
what kind of good game you going to pass
on to your kids
facts hey you know what i'm saying so i
just try to stay i try to stay
cause my little girl's damn they're
smarter than me right doing homework
uh six that's the one i'm talking about
but uh i got one
six and another one too but smarter than
me
bro we doing homework and you know she
trying to tell me like that's the right
answer dad i'm like nah i don't think
this is right
she's right she's right so now you know
i just got to stay on my toes but hell
yeah i appreciate that bro that's what
we in it for man
a whole lot of growth man that's you
know i'm i'm embracing
i'm embracing uh that og status um
you talk about finance financial
literacy which i feel like all of us
usually learn the hard way mm-hmm
whether it's [ __ ] off money we
shouldn't have [ __ ] off or
[ __ ] like owing the taxes whatever it is
like
for people watching like what do you
what is like one thing you could say to
them like they should
be on their toes about when it comes to
bread because that's not something that
gets taught in school
um i just feel like you should you
should treat it the same way you treat
anything else
if a female want her breasts done yeah
i'm saying me she gonna go tweak on a
doctor
she's gonna look at all type of pictures
and makeovers
she's gonna study it she's gonna look at
what what what what causes what i can
get ugly for it right yeah i'm seeing me
um if you want to become an attorney you
can you're going to study
you go study bro i feel like that's the
same thing you want to get rich you need
to study you need to study financial
literacy
you need to know the ins and outs of the
game that you plan
you need to know how to how to how to
manage money you need to know how to um
you know invest money you just it's you
got to learn money that's it i just feel
like you you have to educate yourself
we wouldn't know our math our our
additions nor subtraction
if nobody educated us on that and so um
we won't know how to deal with money i
don't care who you are what you think
you ain't gonna know how to really play
with money man if you don't educate
yourself
on it if it doesn't uh you know if it
don't come natural
i remember when you posted that
screenshot of your bank account
i was tripping everybody was like yo
yeah i needed some
i needed some financial education there
man i was tweaked out
what did he do but now you know i was
trying to um i was just
motivation yeah i was just trying to
motivate the young man that this real
like is
you know cause it i could tell you i got
a million dollars a rapper can say you
got a million dollars
and you know that's what i'm saying made
us we'll look at that as an opinion
not fact that's an opinion yeah like
yeah you might have a million but
you might you probably ran you sold all
your jewelry yeah you probably didn't
touch the million dollars but you ain't
got a million liquid
yeah you ain't got nothing man come on
so i just wanted to show my youngins
and send them trenches cause you know i
still pull up like regular fella
i'm pulling up regular real [ __ ] i'm
jumping out i'm him i'm still
in them places where you shouldn't be
you got a million dollars
and i just want to show them like [ __ ]
like us me and you we
i'm saying we're the same and if i can
go get that emberly you can go get that
amberly it's
it's it's um it's attainable um
the album title beyond bulletproof talk
about why that what
what's the significance of that time to
love one unconditionally beyond
bulletproof it means um
bulletproof man i love you boy leia
bulletproof
i mean it's you know the love that i got
for you is
it it can't be penetrated man can't
nothing is it's teflon
right and then yeah i'm saying we ain't
going through that can't then disturb
what we got going on man can't even
penetrate the surface
so um you know that's bulletproof i'm
let you know it's beyond bulletproof man
and that's i'm specifically talking to
the forgotten
the overlooked the um you know the ones
that
we tend to unconsciously forget about
the ones that send themselves them jail
cells
the ones that i'm seeing me
less fortunate is that is that what the
story behind the album cover too like
who's in the car with you
yeah that's the less fortunate that's my
people i'm hunking i'ma call them
uncanny
right that's hunking them uh i pulled up
skid row
told them get in slid through the
trenches slid through hollywood smoke
some good dope well them took them to
boston novas
bust down yeah i'm seeing me a little
chicken on fires
and then jump back in the low took a
couple photos you know i'm saying we
went on about my day
my opponent sent me the photos that was
platinum velvet i'm like what's this
you know this look like album cover
material right
ran the play that's him beyond proof
that explain everything that's going on
in the cover i'll lay you
unconditionally no matter your
circumstances
beautiful 100 um we talked about
you doing a lot of collab projects you
obviously i i love slimy individuals
oh that's my boy shout out big burn
slime individuals
crazy yeah i mean [ __ ] logic was on
there yg was on i mean it was it was
that's burned too that i ain't gonna lie
not only was you i'm saying
not only did we go half on the project
but he went 100
on production hell yeah he he ran every
play autumn plays
a beat was that's his selection every
feature
that's him tapping into his men's in
them pulled up
um it went crazy man shot studio we went
to his studio where he recorded that
i'm saying he smoked all his weed
i mean he's got a lot of weeds a lot he
made he made my
job heck's a hella extra easy just come
in do what you're doing
yeah watch out i got the merch i take
care of that
block he did this dougie man shout out
to burn we we found a double back on the
double back too as well i was gonna ask
you what's like
another who's who's an artist that you
would like to do another like a do a
collab project with
that you haven't yet it's hello artists
out there
to name a few um you know you got the
little babies
futures yeah i [ __ ] with atlanta tough
me and lucci we got something on the way
way on the freeway
uh i like to do something with um
who out there all right you know dave
east be talking that [ __ ]
oh you and davis would be perfect yeah
you guys have worked together
you guys album came out on the same day
a couple years ago yeah that's my dog
um i'll let it do one with anthony
hamilton just a whole soulful
album anthony hamilton yeah that would
be some all-time ill [ __ ]
yeah uh who else you i
just have you tapped in with the
griselda guys yet
i just hit benny just tapped in with the
butcher
that'd be crazy i just tapped in last
night you know surf he tapped me in
better better that you need to [ __ ] with
the okay
my yeah yeah benny's like i feel like
what you are for the west coast those
guys right now for the east coast
hell yeah that's a squad i function with
him
uh and i want to hear you and freddie
gibbs rapped on the scene yeah that's my
boy come on
gibbs big dog i function with him heavy
yeah fella nice there's a lot of people
i love to collab with man a lot of r b
too so you know eric bellinger's on the
album that's i mean you guys
did the remake
was that was that easy sample to get
cleared i don't know i think they beat
us upside our forehead about their
sample
g-o-d i think they beat us upside down
forehead but
you know i'm saying uh gang man made it
shake man so we we're here
it's present make sure y'all go snatch
that too which sample was harder that
one or the tupac one
i ain't want to touch tupac i didn't
want to touch it
they forced me to do that i didn't want
to touch it so you didn't want to do
that record
i didn't want to touch it that's poc i
don't want to touch nothing that got to
do with pac man that's
i just got that type of respect for him
like i don't even want to only want to
play with it
so i mean that that was a dope record no
it was a dope record and the whole roll
out of it it was a dope play i function
with the whole play but it was something
that you felt was a little forced and
something that you really didn't feel
i when i did it i loved it fell in love
with it i was juiced
i'm ecstatic about how it turned out the
um you know the response from the people
the whole night but
um you know before i before i even wrote
to it when he pulled the beat up
i'm like i don't want it i don't want to
play with it and they you know they like
well i'm telling this to play we get
whoopee whoo
whoo we'll have uti i'm like guy let's
run the play
because you know i'm i'm i'm not that
competitive with my um with my team i'm
you know if they if they recommend
something and they feel like it's a good
look
and i ran a play and um it was a good
look man
is that a record you regret doing no no
okay i just because i'm [ __ ] with the
record yeah i'm [ __ ] with the record i
just didn't want to touch it before i
touched it
you know i'm saying it after i tested it
out i appreciated it
it's the closest i can get the park man
closest i'm seeing me
as far as you know giving a dedication
and without without directly giving the
dedication right
right so it was dope man it it i loved
it
and every i appreciate everybody that
was involved you know the same dude who
played park was in there
in the video yeah my boy so
it the whole killer kid man i loved it
was crazy yeah you know you did
you did right by it it wasn't like
that's like you know a mag dre record
i love matt
who is uh like your top five all time
ozzy top five brothers
pack dribble pack um
i don't want to leave nobody else so it
gets spunky and you know i'm from the
80s
but i'm going to just give it to you raw
you know the snoops
[ __ ] snoop wayne
dmx dmx is he don't get mentioned enough
in that conversation
um somebody else too
it's somebody else too something about
dmx and his like his ability can
to convey pain through his voice that's
what it is [ __ ] is crazy
that's what it is bro like those prayers
on his albums
all right [ __ ] man i i was crying in one
of his songs
uh that [ __ ] said uh i forget what it
was but he i
cried i cried even on the slipping i'm
falling i can't get up
yep that's my when that come on that
whole belly when he played belly
oh when he played tommy yup yeah
brothers it's that's i function with
dude heavy straight up you got the belly
poster right here and then he got the
the beautiful struggle he endured you
watch him struggle yeah whether through
the drug abuse through the going to jail
blase blase
they're a real one he's just naturally a
real one you know what i don't i i hate
about our generation is like
we like a lot of people try to shame dmx
because of his demons
but nowadays it's like that's just
normal business
that [ __ ] said she would me then she
hugged me
kissed me on my forehead told me that
she loved me i saw that it hurt
you more than it hurt me i'm thinking
damn man how bad could this hurt be
i know now that what you did was all out
of love
what i wouldn't do for one more hug from
grandma
baby it's gonna be okay
yeah that's my [ __ ] right there like
that just that type of [ __ ]
before my grandmother passed that was my
favorite song when my grandmother pet is
all i slapped crazy yo shout out to dmx
that that
i feel like that's something that's in
the room with possibilities he'd be
hopping on
he'd be hopping on people's [ __ ]
sometimes nah i'm gonna go get him
you know i don't even buy versus on pay
for verses that's when you
never pay for a reverse thus far man i'm
like a flawless rip
is you know i don't know i don't got
[ __ ] clear we ain't go let's keep that
we got to get it cleared yeah they got
some [ __ ] cleared man i didn't pay for
[ __ ] to come show up for the video
right i'm saying get them right but i'm
i'm the majority of
of my features and collaborations it's
people that i genuinely [ __ ] with and
they genuinely [ __ ] with me
yeah so i'll never i ain't never really
went out my way but a dmx or
erica baidu my dog just got to anthony
hamilton
them them like my three that i i cash
out on spot let's go
yeah i just want to work with you uh dmx
cause he
that's my childhood that's when they
when they i feel like you i can
i could hear dmx in your [ __ ] yeah
that's my erica bardot that's my
childhood
i just that's what we was and then you
know um anthony hamilton that's granny
i ain't know nothing about it anthony
hamilton granny took me to a show
a little concert and you know i ain't
even want to go with her i'm like you
know that's
old folks [ __ ] she's already doing oh
she she oh gee it's i was raised by
granny
so she'd go to old restaurants old shows
i ain't got time for this i'm 17 16 17
or something
i'm thugging you know what i'm saying
i'm banging old pork fourth avenue blood
right yeah i'm not where i go to the
show that coming from where i'm from
album was crazy what
i go to the show brady took me to church
for sure coming from ron
album i know that whole album to this
classic
shout out jermaine dupree who did a lot
of that yeah yeah
that's my dog though anthony hamilton he
just knocked something out for me too
word yeah oh [ __ ] a song four dedicated
to granny
it was supposed to make the album but
yeah i'm saying my management pump fake
i'm highlighting about it [ __ ] dave
i mean how many i mean i already know
you already got mo i mean you got to be
how many records you sitting on right
now bro at least a 40 pop nine i'm just
talking about dope [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] at
least a little fairy pop
i'm talking about album material [ __ ]
that i approve like yeah we could put
something together for
you know outside of what i approve i got
crazy [ __ ] i just you know it'd be
what you call them like scraps they'd
just be all type of scraps where [ __ ]
just go in there do a verse and right
hook
and never do it and never right right
right right right and then pull it up
four years later like
this [ __ ] was fire yeah [ __ ] we could
have made a hit out of this yo with this
album i feel like you're this has been
the
i feel like y'all's rollout this go
round has been so crazy
and it's so crazy because we're in the
middle of a quarantine you hear me
though
like lucky [ __ ] is lucky quarantine
slid up
and shut [ __ ] down cause they would have
got spunky i'm somebody here they got
spunky
on the radio runs on this tour it would
you know we would have caused hell it
gave a lot of [ __ ] a lot of problems
man but um
i ain't mad at it man i'm loving to
support a lot of people in the industry
getting behind it
i'm i'm just i'm beyond appreciative i
let a whole album
it's really me it's the album that you
know if you ask
[ __ ] what album would you recommend if
you're a first
listener of mizzy it'll be beyond
bulletproof
and not because it's not because it's
new right it's not now
it's great not it's because it's a great
body of work substance in it bro
i got a lot of [ __ ] where where og
person they hear it
and and wouldn't mind their kids
listening to it
that's right you feel me versus just you
know what i'm saying because it's some
[ __ ] that they they
they ain't functioning with they come
from mozzie you know all that body for
body
right right right right [ __ ] body at
the body we body [ __ ]
yeah they like come on man we not you
i'm saying but this beyond bulletproof
uh
it just got a lot of a lot of a lot of
um just good
game bro i can't stress it enough a lot
of good game do you feel the need to
move a little differently because i feel
like now mazza you're like
you know you're that guy bro like on the
low you know what i'm saying like
like as to where you i know you know you
say you'd be where a lot of these
[ __ ] rappers won't go
but i think you know we've seen that
that can that can turn ugly you know
what i'm saying
it could get ugly but like you know i'm
saying these are the sacrifices we make
just based on these our people
that's like you ain't going to your
family reunion because it can get ugly
you're going you're going you're going
to skip out on the family reunion and
going to see granny in there because it
can get ugly
nah [ __ ] i'm finna go see my people i'm
gonna go see my family i'm gonna go see
what
what what what i consider home was close
to my heart
with with the people who met that matter
that i could see the whole world smile
but that don't do nothing to me
i'm affected by seeing those that i love
dearly smile
that's what that's what that's when it
count that's when it makes sense
that's when it's like okay now we own to
something i ain't just do this for the
benefit itself
i did this so so we can all you know i'm
saying we benefit from this situation
and how how can everybody benefit from
the situation
if i'm scared to pull up if i'm scared
to tap in if i'm scared to lock in with
you
if i'm scared to vibe with you if i'm
just scared of your kind how can i be
afraid of my own kind
this is what i do it for so you know
this and that's why
i function with nip so much he died
behind it that [ __ ] died behind him
that's what he was exactly about what
i'm talking about right
about not being afraid to function
amongst your own kind
so uh you know that's just the risk we
take man and i felt like i didn't i
didn't know
i didn't had a lot of gambled a lot a
lot more for a lot less
that's fair man have you um
because you know you've been in your
your fair share of beefs per se
now that you're at a certain level of
success
do you feel like you like let certain
[ __ ] go
like or like maybe like man mozzie from
three years ago might have did this
but i let a lot of [ __ ] go not only to
my success just because
yeah you're right due to the notoriety
man you talked about you being like
yourself improved like i feel like you
know what i'm saying here
right you're right man um i let a lot of
[ __ ] go man cause i understand my
position
i understand what i mean to my people
and the um
you know it i can't afford to go to jail
the [ __ ] losing out
so i let a lot of [ __ ] go straight up
man and uh
you know but at the same time i stand
firm i stand on my principles i stand
firm
and um you know i'ma hold my own ground
i'ma hold my own ground a [ __ ] play
with me
sentimental value never sell the thing
you gave to me hey who the king of
mackeremeno they gonna say it's me
i ain't trying to end up in the pen that
[ __ ] gator me
yeah me that whole that whole boy right
there explained anything
what's your favorite song on the album
all other [ __ ] every day
anytime somebody asked me that one day
it'd be [ __ ] behind
be i mean uh bulletproofly the next day
it'd be betrayed
then i'll be like nah today [ __ ]
unethical and deceitful
then they'd be like now the homies want
to know really the hardest but i'm
functioning with that young scent
it's crazy i can't it's whatever
whatever i'm feeling so right now what
i'm feeling
is um the homies want to know
okay yeah i always want to know we finna
drop the video today
i feel like um that explains everything
that explains everything about the out i
mean that's
that's the core that's the heartbeat of
the album is it harder to shoot the
videos now
if you have like the with polo g or the
record with horrible like
are those like because of what's going
on like it's hella harder i just shot a
quarantine video you're going to see
that [ __ ]
but not it's it's most definitely been a
disturbance in the videos
due to the quarantine it's a lot of
[ __ ] i wanted to shoot with
that you know the quarantine didn't even
enable us to shoot with so
um but it's good though cause
i got a lot of work done before you feel
me before the the virus
even hit i i cooked up and i got a lot
of
just good good good memorable moments
for the rollout and um
so i'm satisfied i ain't tripping and
then the rest of it the rest of the
songs i could do to the necklace
so it's been gucci i made it work in my
favor we ain't gonna make no excuses
boom well the album is out uh
great body of work man beyond bullet
proof snatch go get that [ __ ]
um you heard better better man great
body of work great bodywork
the dopest [ __ ] that i dropped thus far
just that i want to run up talk
for me for sure ah that's my boy i
needed somebody to tell me that
no no no they're both i mean i think
they're on par with each other yo mazzy
thank you for coming through brother
yes sir appreciate the plaque too bro
come on man you know you're the fellow
fellow man you already know i appreciate
the unwavering love and support
y'all haven't functioning with me it
feel like since day one not a day
yeah every time we interview somebody i
always try to figure out a way to bring
you up like
yo you [ __ ] mozzie like yeah i'd like
to see you working with mozzie
man oh my god appreciate you brother all
day
perfect
you